So, the teacher isn't getting
to pick questions anymore?
>> No, the teacher's going to do,
the teacher is going to say,
here's where I think the level
of understanding it.
>> Kay.
>> And then,
questions will be generated accordingly.
>> Ooh, maybe from Gaussian.
>> Maybe from a Gaussian, and in fact,
what I'm going to suggest we do is that
we're going to say you
need to pick a line.
Now, why should you pick
one line over the other?
Because I'm going to set up
the incentive, so that you get plus one
any time the learner answers correctly
something they should get wrong.
>> But you also get plus
one when ever the student
gets something incorrect
that they should get right.
So, what does that mean?
So, if you say, well, this is where
their level of understanding is,
what you're really doing is you're
kind of picking two questions, right?
You're you saying, look, this is a
question that they should get right and
this is a question
they should get wrong.
But if you actually identified where
their level of understanding is, then,
sometimes they'll get some of these
things wrong that they should get right
because they're easier, and
sometimes they'll get right some of
the things that they should get wrong.
Sort of set up the problem that way.
>> Okay.
>> Right?
And I'm going to get credit for that.
>> You, the teacher.
>> You, the teacher, I'm the teacher,
going to get credit for that.
Well, let's see, what does that mean?
Well, that means, in order for
that to work, I must have identified,
more or less correctly, where your
level of understanding is as a learner.
>> because if you set it too high,
the learner's always going to get things
wrong, but there are things that
the learner should get wrong, so
there's no points to the teacher.
And if the teacher sets it too easy,
the bar down towards the bottom,
then the learner's never
getting anything wrong.
And when he gets things right,
it's things that the learner
should get right.
And again, should just means
below the bar set by the teacher.
>> That's right.
So, you'll get some
points by doing that, but
you won't get as many as if you get
it right where they ought to be.
>> So, the maximum comes when you've
done this 50-50 thing, right,
where you're getting points for
the learner stretching a little bit and
getting a little bit above and scoring
well, and you're getting points for,
I guess tricking the student in a sense.
>> [LAUGH] I wouldn't say tricking, what
you really is you're sort of testing
where their understanding really is,
right?
So, if it's the case that if
identified this correctly,
will still get some things wrong,
we would think you would get right in,
you'll get some things right that
we think you would get wrong.
You really want to do it on both sides.
And so,
if I move this line too far to one side,
I only get points for
one side of the bar.
If I move things this far, all the way
over to the right, I only get points for
the other side of the bar.
I want to get things for
both sides of the bar.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, that's only going to happen,
if I can identify roughly where your
level of understanding actually is.
>> That's clever.
>> That is kind of clever.
>> Did you come up with this?
>> I came up with this by listening to a
guy named Jordan when he told me this is
what he ended up doing with real
class of, I think, fifth graders.
>> Interesting.
>> Now, by the way,
there's something subtle here,
we actually aren't finished with this.
We just described this as
if it only happens once.
Really, what we did is we spend our
time talking about the teacher, and that
makes sense, because the teacher is this
complicated incentive function, right?
So, the teacher's
going to get credit for
basically identifying where
your level of understanding is.
So, let's say I've done that, I know
where your level of understanding is.
I put the line here.
>> Good.
>> What should you, what it's
going to happen for you as a learner.
Your goal is still to
maximize your points.
So, how do you maximize your points?
>> Well, learner's perspective,
just try to always answer correctly.
>> Right.
So, how are you going to start answering
things correctly, getting more and
more things right?
>> By learning?
>> By learning, by actually moving
your actual bar to the right.
>> I see.
>> Because then, you will not
get these things wrong anymore,
and you will get these things right.
And so, you will increase
the number of points that you get.
>> Got it.
>> So
then, this will cause you to learn more
so that you can get more things right.
And then,
what's going to happen to the teacher?
>> Teacher's going to be unhappy, but
the teacher could move
the bar to the right.
>> Right.
>> To kind of catch up to
where you actually are.
>> Right, so the learner is
incentivized to learn, and the teacher
is incentivized to understand really
what the learner has learned.
And they will keep pushing each other
until you've learned everything.
>> Ooh, and then,
no one has any incentives anymore.
>> Yeah, but at that point,
you know everything.
And you're a teenager.
>> [LAUGH] Well, I was just
worried about this case where, so
then the learner feigns ignorance for
a little while so the teacher can
move the bar down, and then, starts
getting things right and wrong again.
Yeah, I don't know,
I guess that's not really a concern.
>> Yeah, I don't think so.
>> Okay.
>> And even if it is,
the teacher will immediately
figure this out, and
the learner will be giving
up points in the meantime.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not really the maximal policy.
I mean you'd have to
get it exactly right.
>> Right.
It's just that once the learners
learned everything,
the teacher has no incentive anymore.
>> Sure, but then once the learners
learn everything, then you're done.